[Music]
earlier today Apple released the new
version of their mobile operating system
iOS 7 now it's supposed to be a pretty
major update and I've been excited about
this for a while I can't wait till but
you should really be careful because the
new one the new updates can frequently
be very buggy and it's probably not the
best idea to download it on the first
day nah wait a little bit no no I don't
care I'm one of those guys that needs to
download it immediately I'm dying to
check it out and you know what if you
don't mind ladies and gentlemen I know
we're in the middle of a show but I'm
gonna update it right now really quickly
it'll just take a second all right this
is gonna take just a minute I don't come
on no I don't think that I think it's
gonna be fine gonna be a little buggy
you know it's gonna be buggin I've
really nailed my impression of you all
right it's getting ready to install
right now I see I think it's gonna mess
up your phones yeah careful here we go
AHS problem yeah yeah ten percent
complete okay
twenty percent complete okay all right
yeah thirty percent this is going pretty
fast it's going well it's going very
fast yeah this is going well
what it what is happening it's just
updating my profile don't worry about it
[Music]
we please stop updating your phone it's
almost done
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
today it's a giant PEZ dispenser
get inside Conan they'll never know
he'll never know we're gonna take a
break we're back set greens